Rose Leslie shows off her engagement
ring from Kit Harington the Game of
Thrones actor popped the question to his
co-star turned fiance last month
luckily the lady agreed that it was okay
and on Sunday the 30-year old actress
was spotted out and about sporting her
new bling that's nice to hear that's
rose at Heathrow Airport in London
rocking a cozy tweed jacket brown
crossbody bag and her impressive rock I
know it those photos out there an
oval-shaped diamond set on a yellow gold
band the lovebirds confirmed the
exciting news with a formal announcement
published in The Times of London last
month no kidding and during a recent
stop by the Jonathan Ross show Kant
revealed that his proposal didn't go
according to plan
it was gonna string up some lights and
some trees and do all the romantic stuff
and but we were in the country and we
were sort of under this beautiful night
sky and had the love fire burning and
red wine all I meant says I thought my
question a bit early no et caught up
with kit in July at the game of their
own season 7 premiere and he couldn't
help but gush over his real life leading
lady we met on this show and here we are
7 years down the line back here
promoting season 70
and that's it's mad it's such a special
thing I'm so so privileged